YESTERDAY WHILE THE BLUE JACKETS
WERE ON THE ROAD FINISHING UP
THAT ROAD TRIP IN WASHIHIWILL WE
CHECKED AWAY UP ON THAT LEFT ST.
LOOSE PUCK IN THE SLOT.
HUSTLED
ZONEROLLING AROUND YOU CAN SEE E
PURSUIT OF THE PUCK
THE LINE, SHARKS COME UP WITH
PUCK, MAKES THISD THE PUCK PICKD
>> THERE'S BARABANOV WITH THAT
PASS AND CARLSSON KNOWS WHAT TO
WING TOP OF THE CIRCLE. TRIES TO
ROBINSON, IT LOOKS LIKE THAT
PUCK
ELVIS TALKING TO THE YOU
COME DOWN FEED.
THE SHOT IS BLOCKED HERE COME
DEEP AND HE SEES HOFFMAN
COMING WITH H T, AND GAVRIKOV WD
ACROSS ICE.
PEEKE LEFT WING,
NICE CHIP PLAY HERE BY MAX WINGE
CENTERING IT'S A
HERTL CHASED BY KURALY.
THRORO
THERE ROLLING PLAY WILL
SEND IT OFF THEE THE PUCK
COMES OUT YOU SEE MILTON TRIES
TO KEEP IT IN THEN THE RACE HER.
PUCK GETS CLEAREDG, IT'S
WERENSKI WHO FLIPS ITAFTER --
>> HE SHOULD HAVE TAKEN IT